in this course you will learn the
process of building your very own
personal website using a powerful Tech
stack you'll learn how to create a
stunning front end with nexjs13 manage
content on the back end efficiently with
sanity.io and leverage the benefits of
Tailwind CSS for styling and typescript
for type safety by the end of this
comprehensive tutorial you'll have a
fully deployed functional personal
website that you can proudly showcase
and continue to build upon kapehe
teaches this course she is a senior
developer Relations Specialist at
sanity.io this course was made possible
in part thanks to a grant from sanity
Aloha everyone my name is kapehe you can
call me cap short so I'm super excited
for today's tutorial we are going to be
building our very own personal websites
so we'll have a list of projects a nice
way for others to contact you and more
so our personal website will be built
with nexjs sanity.io Tailwind CSS and
typescript so you will need a basic
understanding of JavaScript react how to
use the terminal and a general coding
knowledge
so what is next.js next JS is a flexible
react framework that gives you building
blocks to create fast web applications
so you can check out their website you
can click on start learning to kind of
get a basic understanding of it we will
be going over all the basic steps to get
started as well but we can also Deploy
on versus and today we will be deploying
on Purcell so if you want to learn more
about that on your own you can
definitely visit the website
next we will be having sanity.io manage
our content back-end it has a real-time
data store supporting apis for assets
user management and the sanity studio so
we will be embedding our own sanity
Studio into our next JS app so we'll all
be very seamless
now to get started with sanity.io go to
sanity.io click on start building and
you will need to create your own login
so definitely go ahead and go and do
that now we will be using sanity schemas
today so this is the docs page for the
sanity schemas we'll be using a variety
of these and this will be able to let us
set up our Studios so we'll be using
image string URL I highly recommend
going into these schemas and learning
more about what they can do for us and
what things are required in our code for
schemas but we will be using a lot of
schemas today so definitely go and set
up your own account
now for everyone watching today
YouTubers do get a boosted free plan
everything we'll be doing today with
sanity is going to be in that free plan
but to get that boosted free plan visit
sanity.io YouTube You're Going to click
on the get started button right here now
what does this plan include here's the
list of things that are doubled 200 000
API requests plus more so definitely
head to sanity.io YouTube to get your
own boosted free plan with sanity
what is Tailwind CSS it is going to be
the CSS framework that we will be using
it is a utility first CSS framework
filled with these various classes and
you'll see us typing these out
throughout the tutorial so definitely go
ahead get started if you'd like to learn
more about it but we will be going
through all this installation together
and lastly we will be using typescript
it's a programming language that builds
on JavaScript that strongly uses types
it helps with things like errors and
autocomplete so if you aren't familiar
with job or with typescript but you're
familiar with JavaScript it won't be too
different in your eyes but we will again
walk through all this together
now that we know what we need to get
started and the different types of
um technologies that we will be using
today let me show you exactly what our
finished project is going to look like
okay so here's what our finished project
will look like we'll have our navbar our
header and our list of projects that we
map over
so we'll have our header and then maybe
a little description that we have
underneath about ourselves what we do
maybe where we work and then within
projects we will list our various
projects
so for this one I have only one listed
but once we add them they'll just come
into a grid each one is clickable and it
takes us to a specific page for that
project
here's a little description
explaining what the project is and maybe
how you built it why you built it
and then up here if we click on view
project it will take you directly to the
project itself and then you can
view the project
people can click around for this one
it's a YouTube video now this will take
us back to the home page
now these two are coming directly from
sanity and we created a Pages section so
one of the pages we created was a
contact page and it will you can just
have different information about
yourself an email maybe a Twitter handle
but this will be our contact page and
then again you can name these whatever
you want you can have any content you
want on these
this is all coming from the sanity
Studio
and then the photo gallery this is one I
picked and we could just have a bunch of
wacky pictures like oh that go here and
maybe we took maybe there's a
photographer a photographer so yeah this
is what our final project will look like
and this is built with next.js version
13 and Sandy sanity.io the V3 version of
the studio
we will also be using typescript and we
will be using Tailwind CSS for styling
and the really cool thing about this
project is that because we will be using
sanity V3 Studio
we can drop it right into the next
project embed the entire thing so this
will all be in one GitHub repo and it'll
be really nice to maintain since
everything's located together on one URL
next up we're going to start with our
next JS app we're going to create it
right now and to do that I'll jump over
to my terminal
and I'm going to type in the command
to create a brand new Next application
and that's going to be npx create Dash
next Dash app and we're going to make
sure we put at latest
and once I hit enter there we're going
to see a nice walkthrough
so I'm going to say yes let's install
this package and we're going to name our
project next sanity you can name it
whatever you'd like I probably shouldn't
have named it next Dash sanity because
it is the same name as the sanity
Library we're about to use but oh well
would you like to use typescript we are
going to use typescript it will help
with a little bit of autocomplete help
us find errors and generally really
helpful to have in a project so yes
would we like to use eslint this will
help us catch some error so click yes
for eslint
would we like to use a source directory
this kind of a personal preference if
you use the source directory everything
gets thrown into a source directory and
everything will just live under there
so you'll have your app directory inside
of that
for us we're just going to stick with
the default for no so that our project
will actually use the app directory
so the app directory is a next 13 thing
so we'll click no here and here we go
this is a fun one would you like to use
experimental app directory which is
brand new
we are going to say yes so press right
and you can click yes right here and
we're going to hit enter
and then what import Alias would you
like to configure we're going to stick
with the default here and just press
enter all right
so that is going
doing its thing
all right so we have a brand new Next
js13 application with the new app folder
so this is actually a great introduction
to next 13's app folder so if you
haven't used the app folder
this video will walk you through how to
use it
a lot of different changes that are
happening if you're coming over from the
pages folder as you may already know in
next app so at the recording of this
video the app folder is still in beta
that might change by the time you watch
this but just be sure to go check out
the docs to see if the app folder is
still in beta
all right so we have our app inside of
next Dash sanity it's going to go we're
going to use CD to get into our app
let's do npm run Dev here just get our
project up and running and
it's going
and here we go
so we have compiled over at localhost
3000 we're going to get back to the
browser and refresh and there we go
next.js13 look at that brand new landing
page super cool I really like the Styles
here and that's going to set us up for
the rest of this tutorial
okay so now that we have our next JS app
up and running we'll just leave this for
a second so we can set up our content
back in using sanity
so we're going to go back to our
terminal and we'll open up a new
terminal
we'll leave that one running
so let's go back because we don't want
to create this within our next project
so here we're going to create our sanity
project to do that
run the command npm create sanity at
latest
and we want to make sure we do the at
latest so we get the latest version of
sanity and this will be using the V3
version of the studio which is
definitely what we want to use create
new project hit enter now your project
name we can name this anything we want
but I'll just match it up with our next
project and we'll do next sanity Studio
again you can name this anything you
want hit enter select organization to
attach it to I'm going to click none for
this so hit enter
default data set do y for yes and hit
enter
we definitely want to use a production
data set for this it's so it's creating
that for us does that path look correct
it does we're going to hit enter
now there are different templates that
we can choose from some have schemas
with sample data some have just schemas
but we want to arrow down to the clean
project with no predefined schemas and
hit enter we do want it to be just a
blank slate for us
do we want to use typescript yes so why
and then enter
and package manager npm so hit enter on
that
and it is creating our sanity studio for
us
so once this is done it will live at
localhost 3333
and we are creating this in a different
folder completely different from our
next app but we will soon be embedding
this project into that next app but we
will do that in a second
so I'm going to CD into next sanity
Studio because that's what we named it
hit enter and
we're just going to run it so npm run
Dev to get the sanity Studio running at
localhost 3333
let it do that for us and it's going
perfect so now it's running locally
at localhost 3333 we're going to open
that up
we're going to log in
and we have
our project up and running
perfect
so I just want to pause here for a
second and kind of talk about the studio
so the studio is a web app that is
written in react right now we are
running it locally on our computer where
we can edit it and customize it
currently we are looking at the desk
tool of the studio
so the studio is connected to a
real-time hosted content link there is
no local content so what you do get
synced automatically to the said content
link
so we can deploy the studio to the web
once we think it's ready to use and once
we have our updates we won't be
deploying this separate from the next
app because we are embedding it so once
it's deployed
with our next app we will have the
online version to work with content you
can invite others and collaborate and
all that good stuff
so at the end of this video we will
deploy our next app
and because it's embedded
that will automatically deploy the
sanity Studio as well
so let's go back to our terminal and
let's actually open it up in vs code
so we're going to I'm going to do the
shortcut code space period
so here's our project let me get it back
up and running npm run Dev
so now that it's still running at
localhost 333
I just want to point out a couple of
things this again is where you could do
a lot of your schema building
we'll talk about schemas more in just a
second you can do your schema building
you could configure your entire sanity
project here but again we will be doing
all of that in our next app folder I
just want to show you kind of what it
looks like out of the box here
so the sanity config file is a really
important one for us to note
so this project ID is what we will be
taking over to our next project so that
it knows what sanity project to look at
and which data set to pull from
so these two the project ID and data set
are very important to note
so once you have your sanity project up
and running definitely go to that sanity
config file and find out what your
project ID and data set are those don't
need to be kept private because none of
you have access to this so unless you
have been granted access or invited
through a sanity manage dashboard you
can't actually get into it so you don't
really need to keep this private
Okay so
here's our schemas folder in here
we could be listing out different
schemas but because we're going to be
embedding we will not do that here right
now but this is where we kind of tell
our studio what to look like what fields
to have
but I want to talk about the content
like
so all of this content lives in a cloud
we call this Cloud the content link and
all this happens within data sets so a
data set is a collection of Json
documents that can be of different types
and have references to each other
as we start adding schemas and inputting
content we will be able to see the raw
Json of our data
so we are going to actually go to
our manage
manage.sanity.io dashboard
in that studio we just made is this top
one so we're going to do next sanity
Studio click on that and I just want to
show this off for a quick second so
notice that project ID that lives here
this is where I can invite project
members like I was saying earlier
so if I wanted one of you to collaborate
with me on this project I would click
there put in your email address send the
invite and then whatever role I want you
to have
I want to also point out API
so right now our data is only allowed to
be viewed at localhost 3333
once we start embedding this into our
next app we will need to add localhost
33 or localhost 3000 and once we deploy
this we will need to add our URL
that we used in the deployed version so
we would do add course origin put in
that URL allow credentials and then save
so right now
we can actually add in localhost 3000
allow credentials save that so now when
we embed this right away our next app
will be able to see the entire data set
for this project and all data that goes
with it
now we have our project and our sanity
files
so to query for our content we are going
to be using grok when you use sanity you
can use either grok or graphql but for
this video we are going to be using grok
and we'll look into what that is and how
to use it and what kind of queries we'll
grab what particular data but this
Vision plugin is our playground kind of
for this particular Studio
so we can write our query in here click
Fetch and it will show us exactly what
content we would get back with that
query so
sanity's open source query language it
lets you query any collection of Json
documents and filter them down to
exactly what you need by their
properties and their value it also lets
you reshape and reform that data using
projections and functions we're going to
be using grok to query for all of our
data today so you'll definitely have a
handle on grok by the end of this video
so using the vision plugin it lets us
query for our content for this specific
data set in this studio
and that is getting our sanity project
up and running so right now we have our
content back in already we don't want to
stay in this vs code
and in this folder for any more of our
sanity project
we want to actually embed this entire
sanity project into our next app
so we'll do all the code over there so
the next thing we're going to do I'm
going to actually stop this server and
make sure it's not running anymore
and we are going to move on to embedding
our sanity Studio into our next app
all right this is the moment we've been
waiting for so we're finally going to
get our sanity Studio which we have
separate right now and we're going to
embed that right into our next JS
project So currently we have two
separate folders We have neck sanity we
have next sanity Studio
that we're going to get rid of this next
sanity studio and just drop it right
into next.js
and we're going to have one single repo
for both next JS and Sanity so let's get
started
we are currently in the vs code project
for next sanity studio so this is a
sanity Studios project
there was only one thing we need out of
this project and that's going to be
right here in the sanity.config.ts
we need the project ID so I'm going to
copy that and then we'll go over to the
vs code project for the next JS app and
will only work in there for the rest of
this video
so I'm going to go ahead go ahead and
close this vs code project and here I
have my terminal I'm going to actually
close this out let's cancel this
I'm going to open up this folder in code
and here we have the nexjs project in vs
code
and the one thing I'm going to do next
is go into my terminal and then make
sure I do npm run Dev since we closed it
out in the other terminal
and now that is running I'm just going
to go ahead and close the terminal there
and now we are ready to roll use Ctrl
tilde to open and close that so first up
let's take a tour of the next 13 in this
new app folder this might look a little
different for some of you if you're
coming from the pages folder and overall
things are pretty close to the way they
were but there are a couple of different
conventions that were changed as far as
routing file names and where we're going
to place things
so let's take a look at the home page
for our next app I'm going to actually
close out this terminal here we only
need vs code and the browser
I'll go over to my browser
and let's go to the next JS app which is
localhost 3000
this homepage right here is under app
slash page dot TSX
and that's similar to how it was before
with Pages slash
index.tsx but let's jump back over
and here in page.tsx this is our home
page
everything you just saw is all right
here in our react.jsx now I want to show
you a little bit about the routing let's
say I wanted to create an about page
Well normally you would go into the
pages folder you'd go a new file and
you'd go about dot TSX
and that would be a route but now you're
going to have to do about is the folder
name slash page dot TSX
so now you have a folder called about
and then page is the actual contents or
the react component for that page
and you might be wondering well that's
kind of interesting because now there's
a little bit of more files that I have
to create the benefit here is you can do
multiple files underneath this about
page or this about folder about route
whatever you want to call it and it can
apply to just this route
and what I mean by that is let's see
let's say we have this page let's do a
page right here let's do the about page
return about page
and I'll save that
and we'll go back over to this let's go
to slash about
and
that's our about page
so this actually brings us a couple of
benefits since we can Nest our routes
so this is the about page and then let's
say we want to do a new file under here
which is actually let's create a folder
page dot TSX
so now which when we have a slash Cape
is going to be our routing but the
benefit to this setup right here is that
you'll notice under the app folder
there's a layout.tsx which is actually
the layout for our entire application
so I can create a layout also inside of
about layout dot TSX and that layout is
going to Nest inside of that layout and
then apply to all of these child routes
so there's a lot of really cool things
that you can do with new fault this new
folder structure and nested routing and
nested layouts are actually a lot easier
than the new way of doing doing things
now this just scratches the surface of
what you can do with routing but overall
what you need to know at this point is
that a folder is going to correspond to
the URL and then page.tsx inside of that
will be actually the component that is
rendered for that route
and the same thing goes with the dynamic
routes that were used before
and I'll show you how those work as well
for now let's delete this about folder
and let's get back into it
okay so what we'll be doing next is
actually embedding the sanity studio
right into a route that we'll Define
right inside of this app folder so first
things first let's go ahead and install
some things I'm going to stop my
terminal
let's clear this out and I'm going to
say npm install sanity which is the main
sanity package that we're going to need
and next Dash sanity is the library that
we will need not to be confused with the
name of our project I definitely should
have named the same thing oops sorry
everyone but that's where a lot of the
magic is going to come from so all right
we have those packages installed how do
we start using them we are going to
let's first start our Dev server again
so let's close that out
let's go to our sidebar and what we're
going to do right inside the root of our
project
we're going to create a new file and
we're going to call it
sanity.config.ts and this is where we're
going to Define all the things for our
sanity project
and a lot of this is going to come from
what we did before when we ran npm
create sanity
now the way we're going to set this file
up is we are going to Define
config
from sanity so import that
and then we are going to use that Define
config function to const config is equal
to Define config and we're going to pass
out an object and then we're going to
export default config
next up we are going to pass in a couple
of things that are needed by sanity like
project ID
this is a thing we're going to copy over
from the other project that we just
created
we're going to have our data set
and that's going to be production
and this would be cool if you had
multiple data sets that you created and
maybe one for development one for
production
we'll have title uh let's go for my
personal website
the API version is going to be
today's date which is 2023-0-3-04
cool and when you create this you can
just go ahead and use the current date I
know some apis are going to ask you to
do a specific date but if you just use
the current date sanity will know what
to use
now this is going to be an important one
base path
this is going to be the URL for where we
want our sanity Studio to live
so if you have a website and you wanted
to have people edit content at slash
admin then we're going to do slash admin
right here
if you want to call anything you want
you can write that in right here like
slash Studio
and then you can create the route for it
inside of our app folder
all right so the next thing we need to
do is plugins and we're going to bring
in a plugin called the desk tool
that comes from sanity we're going to go
up to the top here and import that
import desk tool from sanity desk the
desk tool is a top level view within the
sanity Studio we need this plugin to
view our studio at all so definitely
make sure you have this plugin
next up let's go ahead and embed the
sanity studio right into next.js
so I'm going to open up my sidebar go
into the app folder and we want
everything at slash admin to go to our
studio
so we'll be using a catch-all route so
that anything you type in after slash
admin actually gets sent to one route
and the way we used to do that in the
pages folder was with the little square
brackets in our route file name
and here we're going to do the exact
same thing so we're going to say slash
admin and this is where we're going to
use the double brackets dot dot dot
index
slash page dot TSX and that's kind of
like a wild card so it says all routes
under admin are going to go to this
page.tsx
now we're going to use the next sanity
package here and I highly encourage you
to go to the next Dash sanity
GitHub for it and actually look through
the installation instructions and what
you can do with this package
I'm going to just walk you through it
setting it up I highly encourage you to
always go read the docs
so let's close that back up head on back
to our vs code and we're going to say
export default function admin page
and we're going to return and check this
out we're going to say next Studio
which is a component that comes from the
next sanity package
and we're going to say config is equal
to that config that we just created
and just like that that's it that's all
it takes for us to drop in the sanity
Studio into a nexjs app in with the
config file
and the page.tsx for the admin route and
there's a couple more things you need to
add after this but this is really the
gist of it so let's do our Imports real
quick
import next Studio from next sanity
Studio
let's go ahead and import our config
so you can do the import from
dot dot dot since there's a couple
folders up I'm going to go down here to
this config at the end of the word and
type in control spacebar
and we'll just let vs code do the import
for us it's going to click down click
enter and notice how next is actually
using the at as an alias for the root of
our project so you can actually just do
the at sanity config super awesome
all right those are all looking good now
there's one thing left we need to do
that's actually a really specific thing
to next 13. next 13 by default will
actually render all of our Pages under
the app folder from the server
so everything gets rendered on the
server and as little as possible from as
little as possible JavaScript is sent to
our client
compare this to the pages folder way of
doing things where a lot of that
rendering would happen on the client
side next 13 actually tries to move all
that over to the server side so that
it's faster and we ship less less
JavaScript to the client
but since the sanity Studio
is going to be rendered on the client
side of things we actually have to say
use client at the top of this file
and that's a way to signal to next.js
hey this component don't try to render
on the server render it in the browser
on the client
all right so let's go check this out
we're back on the home page we're going
to go to slash admin right here
and this should load up the sanity
studio right inside of next Js
let's see if it works
all right so
here we go we have the sanity Studio
it's doing the whole thing it's asking
for our login make sure you log in with
the correct credentials that you've been
using I'll click Google and check it out
we have the sanity Studio embedded right
into slash admin and this is our next JS
app all we had to do was npm run Dev
inside of our next app and we got the
next app running and the sanity Studio
running so this is great everything
lives at one URL and it will be way more
seamless for any users or clients or
customers or whoever that are using our
site to go to slash admin create content
they log in right there and start
editing
next up we are going to actually get
some stuff into the studio we have no
document types we need to do that and we
are going to create document types and
schemas
and we will show you how to do that and
this is looking great
all right now we have our sanity Studio
dropped into our next.js app but this
isn't real useful for us because we have
no document types so there's not really
content for us to edit or create the
next step here is to add our content
types and as we spoke about earlier
we're going to have a project type so we
can show off all of our cool projects
we're building
and then after that we're going to talk
about the pages type so to start us off
let's add a project type I'm going to go
back into my editor here and let's close
out our folders
all right so where we Define our scheme
is going I'm going to create a new
folder called sanity and then inside of
this we're going to create a new folder
called schemas
and then I'm going to do project Dash
schema dot TSX
and personally I like to put that Dash
schema at the end of it you can leave it
off if you'd like but for me it helps
because soon you'll have a project type
file
you'll have a project schema file
and you'll probably have a route for
projects as well so this helps kind of
know where you're at
all right let's start this off
so we're going to Define our project as
a project is equal to I'm going to go
ahead and Define this object
which is going to Define our sanity
schema so we're going to say name is
Project we're going to say title is
projects and the convention here is I
like naming title as plural and name as
singular
and this is what's going to show up in
our studio the title so that's why it's
capitalized also and this is how we're
going to query for each of our schema
types so I'm going to say type is
document so each one will have name
title type
this is a document type name project
next up we're going to define the fields
of this project so I'm going to type in
a Fields array
and we're going to insert a bunch of
objects and each one is going to
correspond to a field inside this schema
so the first one let's do name is name
and we'll have name title type
and title is going to what going to be
what shows in the studio so we're going
to do capital name
and let's go for type is string
the next one let's do name is Slug title
is Slug
slug
and then type is going to be you might
think this is going to be a string but
it's actually actually going to be a
type slug
so sanity has a built-in slug type and
we're going to say options
source
is name so it's actually going to Define
Itself by grabbing the information from
the name field pretty handy
and we can always com customize this
later but by default it's just going to
grab what's in the name and slugify it
so that we can use it
the next one is going to be image so I
will do name is image name title type
again title is going to be image with
the capital because it's for the studio
type is going to be image type and
Sanity has a bunch of these schema types
built in you can go check out the docs
for which ones you need to use the ones
that we're using here are going to be
the most most common ones you'll you'll
use so we'll keep going from here
options this is a cool feature that
sanity provides we have hotspot is equal
to true
and this means that in our studio we can
actually zoom in pick a certain section
of the image that will always show up
and I'll show you what that looks like
it's super fun
and then fields are object
for image is actually going to have its
own Fields array and we're going to say
name is Alt always good to have an alt
title alt o and this has to be an object
and the type is a string
so now we have an image field that has
its own fields for Alt
all right let's we've got
some left let's go for name is going to
be URL
title is going to be URL again name
title type and this is going to be the
URL that we point people to for a
certain project that we have on our
personal website type is going to be URL
all right the next one
and the final one right now is going to
be the name is content
we need to actually talk about the
project itself so title is going to be
content type is going to be array
and this is going to be an interesting
one because it's not going to be a
string as you might think that this
should be
so it's going to be an array type so of
type block
and this is sanity's way to do Rich Text
we call it block content and we are
using what we call portable text what
you need to know is that basically if
you do type block then you're going to
be able to do headings
and bolds and all the good like wysiwyg
type stuff you're going to get that
right into your sanity Studio
the last step in this is we need to
export this object export default
and I believe we call it project
all right so we've created our project
schema now let's go ahead and drop this
into our sanity config so we can show
the schema type in our studio
I'll go into
sanity.config.ts and underneath plugins
I'm going to say schema
and this will be an object we're going
to say types is going to be an array and
in this array I'm going to do project
right here
and notice this we're getting this red
squiggly we'll have to import it to do
that do control spacebar and we can
import here from the sanity schemas
project schema
and there we go
we get import at the top thank you vs
code all right so let's go check out our
studio there it is already reloaded
thanks to next and here is the project
and there we go we can just start
writing in here creating new projects
but I have one last thing I want to do
before we close up this section
so I want to do a little bit of
refactoring and organization here
right now we're importing our project
here and as we start getting more
schemas this is going to be a lot of
stuff that we're importing so I want to
clean this up
let's go make a barrel file and put all
of these schemas into one file one thing
so I'm going to write some Wishful
coding here
let's say this would be schemas
and this array would come from import
schemas from
sanity schemas
and that's ideally what we want to see
here so I'm going to go ahead and delete
that and let's go make this Barrel file
that we just wrote out
so I'll go to sanity schemas and then
inside of this folder we'll create a new
index.ts
and this file we're going to import
project from
project Dash schema
and we're going to say const schemas is
equal to an array with project in it and
then we're going to export default
schemas
and this is really just an
organizational thing so we have
everything inside of this one file so as
we build out more schemas we just import
it here and we don't have to adjust our
config because it always comes from that
index.ts file so now all of our schemas
are defined inside of the index.ts and
we just work in the schemas folder when
we want to add new ones
all right next up let's go ahead and
create some projects and then show those
projects right on our home page of our
website
I'm going to go back into my sanity
Studio let's click this new button right
here
and check this out we have this whole
studio just dropped into next JS I'm
going to go ahead and in my name I'm
just going to put a test one here let's
do test and for slug I'm going to click
generate over here and it actually pulls
from the name like we told it to
image and ALT I'll leave blank for now
URL I'll leave blank for now and for
Content I'm going to say my first
project
and we're going to go ahead and click
publish down here
all right so let's go ahead and create
another one just we have a couple to
work with I'll say second test
and we'll generate this slug
and then down here under content I'll
say I'll click bold
second test
so my second test and we'll go ahead and
click publish here so there's a little
bit of bold and that and now we have two
documents four projects that we can go
in and use inside of our application so
I'll go back to our vs code
let's close everything out close all
editors let's close all of our folders
and let's start from here
so the way I want to do this is I want
to go into the sanity folder and I want
to create a new file we're going to call
it sanity Dash
utils.ts
and inside of this file we're going to
put all the functions that we're going
to use to go grab data
for is for instance Let's do an export
async function called get projects
and this is where we're going to use our
query language called grok to go ahead
and grab those projects that we just
created
so let's go ahead and write that in
I'm going to do one const client is
equal to create client
and we're going to pass in a config here
and this is so that we can use the next
sanity package to create a client that
can read from our content like
so we'll pass in an object here for our
config
and our config is going to look like
something similar to what we had in our
sanity.config but it's going to be just
a little different
so this client that we're about to
create is all going to do all it's going
to do is read from our content the
config that we had in sanity.config was
more to generate our sanity Studio
so only a few things from here are
necessary like we're not going to need
plugins we're not going to need schema
we're not going to need base path so
let's go ahead and grab all of these
right here I'll copy those
and let's drop them into this right here
now we're showing a red squiggly for
create clients we need to import create
client control spacebar and we're going
to add this from next sanity and you'll
see the import at the top there
and it looks like the title is also not
necessary so let's go ahead and delete
that
all right now that we have our client
created we can go ahead and read data
from our studio
next up we are going to take this client
and we are going to do a fetch
so this is where we're going to write
our grok query if you haven't used grok
before just type along with me and I'll
explain these as we go through
we're going to write out grok and this
is going to be the function that we're
going to use to create our query so
let's go ahead and import this up here
I'm going to do grock
and that also comes from the next sanity
package
all right so here let's create our graph
query so type along I'll explain we're
going to start with an asterisk that
grabs everything in our data set and
then here we're going to Define this is
going to filter down what we want to
query for and then open up a projection
and that's the curly brackets
and we will Define exactly what we want
to pull out of here so first up we want
the type
to equal project so it's going to put
all of our projects and it's going to
say hey Brock grab those projects that
we just created and it's going to be
looking for multiple projects and we
want to grab the ID out of it we want to
grab the created at
and then let's do all the things we had
in there
we're going to have name
we're gonna have slug but slug is gonna
be a special case because we had a
schema type of slug
this one was a string this is a slag we
have to do like this Slug and slug dot
currents we're naming sub.current to be
just slug from now on so we're like
renaming it
so
that is that we have the ID created name
slug is slug.current
image is also a special case since the
image type is going to give us image dot
asset
so it's going to pull in the URL out of
that so the URL here is what we're going
to display on our front end so the
image.asset and then reference down to
the URL and that is going to be named
image
URL is a string as a URL schema type so
we can bring that out we have content
and that is it
so we're going to grab all of that and
we're going to go grab
all of our projects
and we haven't actually returned
anything so we're going to do a return
right here and that should be able to
give us our data so we can use it on the
home page and show all of our projects
there and this was queried using grok
all right so that looks good right there
let's go ahead and use this on our home
page
I'm going to go into app
let's go into
page.tsx and this is our homepage let's
go ahead and just wipe this all out so
I'm going to do command shift p to open
up my vs code command palette and I'm
going to type outward this is just a
little trick
you can do if you want I'll press enter
and it highlights everything inside of
that and I'll delete all of that
and we're going to write out my projects
go here
so now we have the starting foundation
for our home page let's go ahead and
remove the Styles and enter from our
custom fonts there we don't need all of
that above there
and now this is our home page so we're
starting out pretty much from scratch so
let's go get those projects and show
them here
the first step here is we are going to
import get projects
from and I'm going to use that Alias at
next jss up for at sanity slash
sanity Dash utils
the next thing we're going to do is
changing up a little bit from next 12 to
next 13. so what you would normally do
if you wanted your data to be fetched on
the server side and shown to your react
component on a page you would normally
do this
you would do export function get static
props
and then if you had a page that had
multiple paths like a dynamic route you
would also have to do export function
get static paths
now in my experience this has been a
little bit harder to wrap my head around
because you have to get static paths
which returns a very specific array of
how next.js
does things and once it's formatted then
it gets static props it's going to
return props and that's going to be an
array or something like that
and you would have to return props which
is going to be an object and let's say
you have projects in there and that
would be an array so very specific way
of doing things but now
in next 13 you can get rid of all of
these and check this out we can just do
get projects cons projects is equal to a
weight get projects so right inside the
function itself
in our is uh our react component we have
projects await get projects and we have
to make sure this is an async function
since we are using a weight but look how
much easier that is to manage because
now it kind of makes sense we just get
projects and we're going to map over the
projects here
now the trick in next 13 all these Pages
under the app folder are by default
server side rendered so since that's the
case all of this is happening on the
server side and then it's splitting out
all it's fitting all the projects
rendered right here so I'm going to do
this projects.map
project
and then we'll do a div and I'm going to
do key is Project dot ID
and then let's just go ahead and show
out the project name
so project.name
and you'll see a typescript error here
saying that the project is any we're
going to fix that when we create our
types but for now let's just make sure
we show these projects on our site
so I'll go back to the home page which
is just localhost 3000
and there we go
so we have tests and we have second
tests we are showing our project so we
had from sanity in this video don't
worry we're going to make these Styles a
lot better looking than what it looks
like right here remember the final
project you saw earlier but right now
let's just celebrate we have our data
and we're able to show it and next.js is
rendering this on the server so this is
really really cool stuff if I go back to
the studio let's go ahead and create a
new project let's call it
we'll stay with test so third test and
we'll generate the slug here
let's go down to Content
I am
the third test
and we'll click publish document was
published let's go see if we see that on
our website
refresh and there we go so third test as
soon as we refresh the page it shows up
and we were able to go get that new data
and show it
all right this is really cool stuff you
can start to see how the flow works from
having our studio content grabbing it
and showing it in the next app and it's
all embedded It's all under one URL
all right if we look at our page.tsx
notice this typescript error right here
if I hover it
project any parameter project implicity
has in any type
all right let's give it a little bit
more of a con a little more of a context
so that vs code can give us some
intellisense some typescript features
like helping us give
us what properties are inside of a
project type
and this is going to help us out when
we're working across our project because
now we get smart intellisense and things
are just going to be easier to find
errors
all right to do this we're going to
create a type for our project so this is
all typescript stuff so let's start
cleaning things out I'm going to close
all my files right here
close this out
so I can config all right so let's go
ahead and create a new folder inside of
here I'm going to say a new folder I'm
going to call it types
and then inside of here I'm going to
create a new file project.ts
and inside of this I'm going to export
type project
is equal to and we're going to do
everything that we have from our schema
we're going to say ID is a string
created at and since it starts with an
underscore that's kind of saying that
sanity created this themselves remember
we didn't create this that's not
something we had to generate it kind of
automatically comes generated for us
that's awesome
um that's going to be a date and then
the ones that we generate ourselves that
we generate ourselves we're going to
Define name String slug is string image
it's going to come back as a string URL
is going to be a string so we're giving
them types
and now this one's going to be an
interesting One content it might you
might think it's going to be a string
but the way that sanity returns it since
we want to want Rich Text like bold
we want images inside of our content we
want
links below block quotes we want good
stuff like that it's not going to do it
if we just say string
so we're actually going to use what is
called portable text block and it's
going to be an array of portable text
blocks and that's how sanity stores Rich
content
um and it's a thing called portable text
so I'm going to import that you can see
a little green thing right here I've
been doing control spacebar to show the
autocomplete but I can also click this
add import from sanity nice thanks vs
code
and there we go to the top imported from
sanity is going to be enough to create
our project type for typescript
all right now how do we use this thing
if I go back to page.tsx it still shows
an error there are a couple of different
ways you could do it right here you can
say project
and then we have to import this project
I'll click on the little green light
bulb add import so that's one way to do
it so now whenever we're typing in
things are here and I say project Dot it
will show check it out ID content image
name slug URL and also tells me the type
so I'll do name right here
so
that's one way to do it another way to
do it is take this typescript type right
here remove it from there and then do it
right here and say project is going to
be an array of objects or an array of
projects sorry like that and we get the
same autocomplete we see that this
parameter is a project type but
personally we will have to write a lot
of code if we use this get projects
um in different files so I don't like
doing it right inside of each file where
we call the get projects function
so let's go all the way to the source
sanity utils get projects right here
we're going to say the return is going
to be a promise and it's going to return
project
and an array of them
so now let's go over here we'll do
import from types project and just like
that since we're doing it inside of our
call where we say get projects now
anywhere that uses get projects like in
here
get projects we hover and it's going to
return a promise that gives an array of
projects so now
if we go over this it knows hey this is
an array of projects and then down here
it also knows that this is a single
project since we're mapping over them
so I think this is a great way to do it
you keep all of your types and Sanity
utils and then your main react
components they don't really show types
but they are typed which is really nice
and we can delete this import now
so that's how we're going to add types
to our projects and use it in our
utility functions
next up let's start making our project
look good it doesn't look the greatest
right now if I go back to my browser
it's just this thing right here let's
make this look a little bit better so
we're going to bring in Tailwind CSS and
Tailwind is a CSS framework that helps
us build websites out really quickly
was kind of taking the entire Dev
ecosystem by storm so if you haven't
used Tailwind I'm going to walk you
through how to style our website and if
you have used telwyn let's start
building out this cool looking website
so here I am on Tailwind cs's homepage
I'm going to click get started and under
framework guides is where we want to go
and next.js is going to be the first
option
we're going to go ahead and just follow
the instructions they did a great job
with these docs let's see and PX create
next app we already have our next app
and next is install Tailwind this is
where we are going to start
so we will copy all of this right here
I'll go back to my vs code open up my
terminal using control tilde
open up new terminal and let's do this
right in here so
all right that is step one that's good
let's go and create our Tailwind config
file
copy that
back to vs code
paste that in
and we have a brand new tailwind.config
in a brand new post CSS dot config
down here we are going to configure our
template path so that Tailwind can
actually look at our templates
and only give us the CSS needed for the
classes that we use
so it keeps our bundle size really
really small
and really the one we want to get here
is the app folder one right here since
that's where our stuff is going to live
and maybe if you're using components you
can use that
or if you want you can just grab it all
and throw it into your Tailwind
config.js
all right and I'm going to replace this
entire content right here
there we go and then I'll go back to the
docs add the Tailwind directives to your
CSS so we're going to take all this and
put this inside of globals.css
and I believe that's the last step until
we can actually just start writing out
Tailwind in our files
so let's go back
I'm going to open up globals.css
under app globals and there's a bunch of
stuff in here that next.js has already
put in so I'm going to go ahead and
delete it all and put in these three
lines and that's all we need to get our
Styles going
another thing I notice is Page dot
module that came with default next
um
with next we don't need that so let's
delete that
all right let's close everything here
let's close our folder structure
so let's start from a good place and
let's go into our terminal
I'm going to close that and let's
actually restart our our Dev server so
npm run Dev it's always a good idea
whenever we build a new build tools like
that
so now I'm going to open up once this is
done I'm going to open up
page.tsx
and let's
let's write out some class names
so class name is equal to BG red 500 so
background
not 50 500.
and back over here to our next JS app
refresh and there we go we have Tailwind
ready to go inside of our app and now we
can start styling out our home page
so let's do this real quick let's delete
that class name is equal to that and the
things I'm going to need here I'm going
to need a div
let's do
class name right here
let's make sure we have a Max width so
maybe with 5xl and MX Auto so that
centers everything we're doing here
then let's create a hero section we're
going to say an H1 and then
I'm going to say Hello I'm
hey close that H1
and next is going to use es link eslint
to tell us hey we want this to be an
entity so we'll do this with the a pause
semicolon thing and we'll replace that
so we can make make next.js happy
perfect
it's looking good all right so let's get
some styles on our H1 so class name
right here is equal to text 7xl and font
extra bold
let's take a look at that save it there
we go that looks good
let me zoom out a bit for now all right
cool
so another thing we can do we can do
padding
y of maybe 20 and get some spacing on
the top and bottom top and bottom and
then a fun effect I want to do I'm going
to wrap this in a span
so I'll put a span right there
and I'm going to say class name let's
give this a gradient this I think is a
very fun effect so PG gradient to write
so we have to give it two colors to
start with and end with so we're going
to say from Orange
purple 600.
and you can even do a middle color so
like we'll do via red 500.
sweet so let's take a look at that
all right so it looks kind of
interesting right now but let's apply it
to the text instead so now with two more
classes we're going to say BG
clip text
and we're going to say text transparent
okay all right okay that looks really
cool so let's keep moving let's go and
add a P tag underneath this H1
so
P I'm going to say aloha everyone
check out my projects
you can say stuff like thanks for
visiting my website all that good stuff
and let's style this a little bit so
class name is equal to margin top three
text extra large XL and text Gray at
600.
we don't want it to be like super dark
so it kind of gives a little bit of a
different differentiation from the H1
above it so let's take a look nice that
looks good
all right let's go ahead and give these
projects a little header to like say my
projects
so right above the projects map I'm
going to say H2
my
projects
and we'll give it a class name I'm going
to do a giant margin top of 24 we'll do
font bold text Gray at 700.
and text 3 XL
and that will give us a nice little
subheading for our projects
let's take a look
nice so it looks really good right there
and now let's style out each of these
projects
we have three of them let's separate
them so we'll go back here I'm going to
say class name
here
is equal to border
border gray at 500
let's give this rounded large
and what we're doing is we're adding a
nice border onto it with these class
names
I'll click save
and then let's style out our project
name I'm going to put div around this
and then we're going to say class name
is equal to we'll do font
extra bold
let's go for another BG gradient
to write
actually we can simplify this yeah let's
just go and copy the one we have up here
might as well just copy it scroll back
down and we'll just do that right here
and we'll save that we also have the
image for these projects so let's go and
say if project.image exists then let's
show an image
I'm going to use next js's image
component here we're going to say source
is equal to project
Dot
and check it out we have all of our
properties things typescript types I'll
say image
and let's go for an ALT oh and I just
realized we didn't bring an ALT from the
studio so you can go ahead and add that
to your sanity utils so that you can
pull the alt for now
for now I'm just going to use
project.name so let's keep moving let's
go for a width of five of 250 a height
of 100
and let's go class name let's say
object
cover so that doesn't go over the width
of the div that it's contained in
let's go for a rounded large and let's
give the image
border border gray 500 and we need to
import next image so I'm going to go to
the top myself
and import image from next slash image
and if you go down here there we go no
errors and that should be good enough to
show our projects on our home page and
have some pretty good styles
so save that let's take a look and there
we go
and our projects are kind of just
punched together like this so let's give
it some spacing next
and I think we're reaching the end of
this we're almost close to being done
with styling our home page so
let's wrap projects
.map
I'm going to shrink that and we'll give
it a class name so div around it class
name will do margin top of five to get
some spacing away from this H2 let's go
for a grid if you haven't used CSS grid
yet this is really a really cool way to
do it we'll do grid grid columns three
and then we want a gap in between each
of these so I'm going to say Gap is 8
and then let's go close the div around
here and that is going to be how we get
our projects
into a grid
yeah isn't CSS grid so cool
um so there we go yeah
now let's also make this responsive that
this is the last part of our Tailwind
for this homepage because if I do they
kind of stay in this grid
so let's go over here
let's see grid columns
three is only on large screens on medium
screen screens grade columns two
and it defaults to grid columns one so
we don't actually need to write grid
columns one but there we go
and I think we should give a little bit
of padding to our project so padding
maybe three
let's go take a look
there we go that looks a lot better
let's scroll over here and look how
responsive that is very cool
now the images aren't showing because we
haven't added any images to our sanity
Studio
but if you add images they should show
up here all right so we've written some
Tailwind we've made our site look pretty
cool and I think we're a really good
path to being able to click on these and
showing each individual project Page by
themselves
next up let's go ahead and Link each of
these individual projects to their own
specific page
right now we're on the home page but if
we wanted to click into one it would
make sense to be able to go to slash
project slash the project slugged slug
so to do this
first of all let's get some real
projects in here we're going to go back
to our sanity Studio
and let's go and delete this third test
I'm going to keep it so delete right
there or I'm going to delete it so
delete right there delete now
and then let's go into test let's go
ahead and
in this case we're just going to add two
YouTube videos so I'm going to add a
couple projects we'll this first one
will be sanity.io crash course
we'll regenerate that slug
image I'm going to upload an image for
the sanity crash course and I have one
right here
there we go
and you'll remember in our schema we
added a hotspot is equal to true in our
image
so if we click the little crop icon
right here we can crop using the drag
handles right here
so if I drag that over there drag it
over here we can also declare we where
we want the hot spot to be so this
basically says if we need to focus on a
certain area of the image
we want it to be there
we want to be there or whatever and we
get the previews down here they're
really nice and you'll notice updating
over here on the left as well and if we
move it over it'll update again so this
is a cool feature from sanity to tell
when we render these images to kind of
focus on a certain area of the image
all right I'll go ahead and close that
one
and we'll keep everything there that's
good I'm going to
paste in our URL from YouTube
let me go back copy this one right here
let's go back to the dashboard and feel
free to add whatever projects you have
of your own
and I'm going to update this to say
sanity
a sanity crash course video and hit
publish
highly recommend watching this by the
way document was published that updates
will go ahead and update this one for
our other projects I'm going to say
groken 2 which is a series that I did on
YouTube that lets you learn how to use
grok in two minute videos
we'll regenerate that we'll upload a new
image
there we go
and let's make sure the hotspot picks
this section over here
where it says groken two and let's do
that
we'll see update over there very cool
we'll copy our grok into URL right here
we'll come back to the studio let's
paste that in
so yeah these are
um Quick videos to learn grok
and I'll go ahead and publish and that
will update that document so we now have
two documents that are ready to go and
I'll go back to our website refresh and
oh let's
so invalid Source prop you'll see that
on next image host named
cdn.sanity is not configured under your
images in next sanity config
or next next config so this is just in
settings in next to say hey I want
images from this URL to show
so let's copy
cdn.sanity.io let's click into this nice
link and they
give us the docs right away
so
um
we'll go into our next config and just
add that really that chunk of code that
was a really great experience with the
next JS docs and that error to give us
the direct link to fix our problem
all right back over here let's go down
to
nextconfig.js and paste this inside of
the next config images
hostname is cdn.sanity.io
we don't need path names so we'll delete
that since we're just worried about the
main URL of the domain let's go back
over here
to our website so this was to handle
images in next
since we're we updated next config let's
see if we need to update our server so
npm run Dev restart that
and let's see if this fixed
so I'll go back over hit refresh
and there we go
we have our app running again
so we have our images showing really
nice I'm seeing a little bit of spacing
issue on those and we'll fix that but
right now we have a great way to show
our projects
let's go ahead and style these out and
link to each of these
so let's go back to vs code I'm going to
go back to the page.tsx file
and let's do a little bit of cleanup on
our Styles our image let's bump up the
width to 750 we'll bump the height to
300. I kind of want to drop this padding
down to one so let's change that to one
and then let's up our border to two
so let's just make those quick changes
and then down here I want to add a
little bit more spacing
let's go from margin top of maybe uh two
so that gets a little more spacing from
the image
all right so let's check that out that
looks better uh maybe a little bit
getting cramped over there but that's
okay let's start linking these so that
they can go to an individual page
so we'll go back over here and instead
of this
div I'm going to make this a link and
we'll change the closing link right here
and we need to import this
so we'll go to the very top of the file
and we'll do import link
from next link
let's scroll down
and here we have an error
probably wants an href yep
href is missing so let's do that
href
and we'll do back takes we're going to
say slash project slash
projects project.slug
so now that each of these is going to
link to their own page with their own
slug
we'll show that from there so now you
can see that this is linkable right here
linkable
if you hover let's go ahead and give
these a little bit more style so that
they show that they're linkable and this
will be the last thing we do on styles
let's go over here to the link and we're
going to say hover
let's do scale at maybe 105 and we'll
say on Hover
border blue at 500 and then we'll also
transition both of these so that it's a
nice transition between these two states
all right
there we go
that looks great
so now if we click one we get slash
project slash sanity
i o crash course but we have a 404 page
could not be found that's because we
haven't created this page yet
so next up we have to create this page
so what we are going to do
is go into our vs code
go into our folder structure under the
app folder
and this is how we are going to create a
dynamic route that is going to be used
for that route
we're going to say new file
and we're going to create the folders in
here as well so project is going to be
the folder
and that corresponds to the first part
of the route we're going to do that with
project and that's going to be the
dynamic part of our route
so when we're passing the slug that is
what is going to be called in as the
project
and then we are going to do page.tsx so
a folder and a route doesn't really
exist until there's a page.tsx under it
so that's how nexjs knows to say okay
I'll create a page for this route so
good to note
if there's no route then it's kind of
private and it doesn't get used or shown
to the public
all right so let's define this thing
right here we're going to export default
function
project
and then we will return a div
my project goes here
now you might be wondering okay so in
next 12 we used to have to get static
paths and get static props here since
it's a dynamic route
well we don't need to do that which is
really really really cool if you're
going to pass in params and we're going
to get that directly from our route and
next.js is going to pass that in
and then we are going to have the const
slug is equal to prams dot project
params is what next.js is going to use
to pass us and the reason is called it's
called projects is because of the file
name right here so if you use this name
differently it would pass in different
params
now that we have the slug let's go ahead
and do const project is equal to a
weight get
project and we're going to pass in the
slug
now this is similar to how we did it in
the page.tsx where we did get projects
and we did it right inside the component
what's cool about this is now we can
start using the project right here
and it seems like a lot simpler code
than get static paths guess static props
it's all just right here in the same
component
all right so we have a couple of things
to do we have some errors let's fix
those I'll do async right here to fix
this await one
let's fix this params type problem it
says it's any let's just give it a type
so it knows what we're looking at
type props is equal to an object and the
object is going to have params and
inside of that we're going to have
project which is a string
and then we'll say this is going to be
props all right
that's the easy ones to fix um right now
we are ready to go except for this get
project we need to declare this thing
and Define it and it hasn't been made
yet
but we do have a sanity utils file that
we can throw all of this in so let's go
over here to sanity
sanity Dash utils and write
now we have export async function get
project so let's do another one
export async function
get project
singular and we're going to pass in the
slug which is a string
and then just like get projects we are
going to return a grout query fetch from
in here
and we can actually type out the return
to so let's say promise and it's going
to return a single project
and the error here is because we're not
actually returning anything out of this
it says uh returning void or any must
have a return value so we're going to
write that in now but this is cool
because we have get projects which
returns an array we have get project
which returns a single project so let's
go ahead and copy this right here
all right let's copy this whole thing
and we'll work off this so I'm going to
copy that let me zoom out
so we can see a little bit better so
we'll copy all of that
and we're going to go down here and
paste that in and the main difference
right here is going to be a minimal one
is that we need to say type is equal to
project
and sub dot current is equal to slug
but this will still return an array of
projects so we want to say take that
first one and that's what the zero does
so find any projects where the slug
equals to the slug I'm passing in and
only give me that one back
and the way we pass in that slug we go
down here and we say slug slug or we can
shorthand that to just slug
and I'll zoom in again
so just like that we have get project
which we can return which will return a
single project
and you might be wondering hey do I have
to write this create client every single
time uh yes but we can actually simplify
this and move this config out so we'll
show you how to do that right after we
get this working
so let's go back to page.tsx here we
need to import get project add import
and now let's do this right here let's
just make sure we have project.name
and let's make sure this works
so let's go back to our browser
we'll hit refresh
and there we go sanity crash course so
we have all the data for that project on
this page and check out what we had to
do we just did the get project right
inside of the function
how cool is that so much less code than
what next 12 did and we're rendering on
the server so we're sending less
JavaScript to render this page on our
browsers awesome
all right so we're in a really good spot
I want to simplify sanity utils a little
bit more so there's a create client
right here
there's a create client right here if we
changed out our project ID or data set
then we would have to change it in
multiple places especially if we had
multiple functions inside of this file
so I'm going to go into our sanity
folder I'm going to create a new file
say config
slash client-config.ts
and that creates a new folder a new file
and the reason I called it client config
is because this is for reading data from
our client which in next which is next
in this case but this one down here is
for creating the studio so that's how I
did I differentiate
so we're going to say const config is
equal to an object
and then we're going to export default
config
and let's go ahead and grab that config
from here and let's go to sanity utils
and I'll copy all of this right here
and I'll paste that into client config
all right now that's looking good and
now I can go back and do sanity utils
and then we can clean this up we can
remove all of this and just do it right
here we're going to say create client
client config
and that we're going to get it from
client
slash client config
so now we are importing it from a
separate file and we can write it out
just like this and it simplifies our
code just a little bit
and now we're not repeating ourselves in
multiple places
so I'll do the same thing here I'll go
down and paste it in right here
just like this
all right so that looks good there and
this one looks good as well much cleaner
we have a little bit more organization
in our sanity folder and we're in a good
spot
but what I am seeing is that if we go
back to the site it does need a little
bit of styling just like our home page
needed
so we have our projects on the home page
we have a single project page next up
let's make sure we style out the page
right here so we can get this to look as
good as our home page does
and we are going to need an
um a nav bar eventually so we can get
back to the home page from here so
let's kick things off I'm going to do
some Tailwind styling on this page and
we're going to bring in some more
content
let's go over to our projects page
page.tsx
and we'll work right in here
we have the project so let's start
showing more parts of the project
so let's go with a header right here
and then on this project name this will
be in H1
and on the right side we're going to do
a href an a tag href this is going to be
project.url
and title is view project
and we're going to do Target is equal to
underscore blank so that opens up a new
tab when you do that just for some
security no opener no refer
and we'll say view project
close that up close that a tag
all right there we go that looks good
let's go see if anything changed it
still looks not that great so let's
start working on that
um we're going to go to our main div
class name is equal to Max with
let's go for 3XL MX Auto so we can
Center it and let's go for padding y of
20s so top and bottom of 20.
our header here let's go class name is
equal to flex so they sit side by side
and let's say justify between
so they go to the left and to the right
so this H1 will go far left this a tab
will go far right and we'll say item
Center so that they are vertically
centered
all right that looks good right there
let's go ahead and style out sanity.io
crash course
we are going to style it like we did the
home page
so if you still have your home page up
go there and find that gradient that we
did let's see right here we're going to
copy this whole thing
and so yeah copy that let's go back over
and we'll paste that to our H1 so class
name is equal to there
okay so let's also style our a tag right
here class name is equal to
background gray 100 let's go for rounded
at large then let's go text Gray at 500.
and then let's go for
um
font bold
I'm padding Y3 padding X4
white space no wrap so so the button and
text doesn't wrap into two separate
lines when we do responsive work let's
save that let's take a look all right
that looks good this is not large enough
so something happened there
um oh we haven't even filed that one so
let's go ahead and add that text
7 XL font extra bold and let's keep it
right there
and then I think this button also needs
a little bit of a hover style so we'll
say hover BG pink 500 however text pink
and then let's give it a transition so
that it transitions between the not
hovered and hovered States
okay
that looks good and maybe a little large
on this text right here so let's drop
that down to maybe uh let's do 5xl and
give it a drop shadow
perfect
all right that looks that looks good
next up let's keep going we're going to
add the content right here
and then we are going to add the image
right here so let's go down
here after the header we're going to add
our content goes here
and then we're going to say image goes
here
so
now to do the content we are going to
add a div
and then here we're going to say project
dot content and this is going to get
interesting because this comes back as
portable text remember portable text and
it's not assignable to react node so we
can't just display it like this we have
to display it in a special way and this
is because it is an array of blocks
which is like paragraphs that have bold
or span tags or italics or block quotes
all kinds of fun formatting that that
isn't easy to do right here
and let's see what this looks like if we
just it just gives us an error right
away and it says can't display this
so the way we can do this is a new
package let's go into our terminal
let's cancel that out clear it out and
we are going to say npm install
at portable Text slash react
and portable text is the tool we're
going to use to show all of our blocks
that we created in the sanity Studio
let's go ahead and npm run Dev again
we'll close up
so how do we use it we are going to go
to the top of this file
and we are going to say import
able
text
and this is importing a component from
at portable
Text slash react
cool and now we can use this component
to display the portable text down below
let's go find that
and this is a lot better than looping
over the project dot content this will
just do all of that work for us and we
can say portable text value is equal to
project dot content like that and that
will display our portable text on the
site
so refresh and there we go
so that's all of our text that we had
it's just text so it might seem like a
lot of work to just to display this text
but if we had more stuff in here like
bolds or fun formatting block quotes
code blocks that would look really good
all things to Portable text
so let's go style that so on this div
we're going to say class name text is
large let's go for text Gray at 700 so
it's not just pure black mt4 for margin
top let's go from margin top five
actually yeah
all right that looks good and now let's
add the image so we're going to go down
here and we're going to say image and
we're going to import the next image
like that right here and we're going to
go to the very top and import image from
next image yep just double checking
so we'll go back down and just like we
did on the home page
source is equal to project dot image
alt is equal to and again you can go
into your sanity utils and bring in the
image alt I'm going to use project.name
right now
um
yeah so we'll say width is going to be
1920 height is going to be 1080.
and then let's give it some classes
class names equal to margin top 10 we'll
go for Border two border gray 700
so it gets a nice border around it we'll
do object cover and rounded
extra large so for that rounded corner
all right that'll be good for that let's
go take a look check it out we have our
project page looking really good we have
our title our content our project right
here
um with this image and the link to go
view the project which actually goes to
the YouTube so very nice and if we go
back to the home page I'll just delete
all of that right here press enter
I can click grok into and all of that is
also dynamically pulled in so very cool
now the next thing we need to get going
to work on is to have a nav bar we need
to create a shared layout between the
home page and the projects page we don't
want to have to create a header and a
nav bar in both of the pages that we
have right here
so if we go to our folder structure we
don't want to create a header in here
and then header in here as well well
lucky for us we have this layout file
that next.js already gave us which the
layout file will will wrap around
everything inside of this folder that it
sits in so let's close everything out
and if I go into this layout file and I
go down here language and body let's go
class name
is equal to BG
pink 500 save that and come back to our
entire yeah and our entire site is pink
so it's working and then if we go to the
main home page
that site should be pink as well so
anything in layout will span everything
for all of our routes so it's working
so have that in mind always do here is
go here the
the body of our content will live right
here and I will say
Main
and then we can have a header here
let's go ahead and do link this is going
to be an xjs link component
we'll say href is going to be the home
page
and let's go for class name is equal to
we're going to do that whole BG gradient
thing again so I'm just going to go back
to the home page
and I'm going to copy this again so
we'll copy that
let's go back to layout
and I'm going to put my name here as the
logo as the logo
and then
let's style it
just a little bit more
I'm gonna go for text large
and font bold
now we need to actually have a link
right here so we're going to do this and
I'm going to import from next slash link
and I'll show you that at the top import
next slash link right here
and while we're here we'll change this
to my awesome site
generated by
the next
plus sanity
that's just metadata
and we'll scroll down all right so we
have our header here and that should
apply to all of our routes something I
also want to do here is go class name
let's put a Max width of 3XL MX Auto and
let's go for padding y of 10 to the
entire site because we did it to the
home page and we did to the single pages
but let's just do it right here on the
main layout
now that means I can go back to this
page and delete this right here
and that's gone and then I can also go
to the projects project page.tsx scroll
to the top
and
delete this right here as well
all right
so let's go back to our site now we have
our nav bar right here we have our
projects we have our hero section right
here let's actually give our spacing on
the main let's actually add some spacing
on the main as well let's go down here
we'll go back to layout down to main
let's say class name is equal to let's
go for padding y of 20 there
yeah
now that should get some spacing away
from the header there it goes so now
that's our header there's our hero and
I'll click on a project and we still
have our logo and we go back to the home
page from here yep
and I can click sanity crash course go
back to the home page so
everything works we have our layout
working like it should but there's going
to be something really interesting that
happens when we update layout
so right here and let me close all these
files
now I want to show you something
interesting that just happened if we go
back to our dashboard toward
Studio notice that our layout applied to
the Studio route as well so our entire
padding and our Max width and our header
are actually showing on the studio page
which is not a great experience anymore
so with that in mind we have to create a
separate layout for the site and a
separate layout for the studio
now this is interesting because this is
a brand new thing for next 13. and maybe
going to be hard to wrap our heads
around but if we have our layout file
this applies to everything in that
folder
so since we can use our folder structure
to Define our routing
we can actually in next 13 now use our
folder structure to Define organization
and what do I mean by using your folders
as organization
so I can create a new folder here and
I'm going to call it site with
parentheses around it and I'm going to
create a new folder and I'm going to
call this studio with parentheses around
it
so these actually don't do anything for
next.js's routing it helps more with
organization
so if I had a layout file in here
that would apply to everything in this
folder
and then if I had a layout file in here
that would apply to everything all the
routes in the site folder so now we have
two different parts of our site
organized using these folders
and I know that might sound interesting
and let me just keep going and show you
how it works so put this layout because
it is a site layout in this site folder
and we'll replace that one
okay
so that works out well let's copy
everything in the site layout
I'm going to copy all of this
and then let's go into the studio layout
and paste that in and I don't want any
of this stuff in here so we're going to
delete all that
okay and this main right here all of our
classes and all of our classes here
that's going to be this studio
layout
and
I believe I don't need the next Link at
the top anymore
yeah
and that's it we actually don't need the
globals.css here as well because the
studio comes with its own styles
all right so we can start moving
everything over into the correct
locations let's get organizing
so let's go ahead and say the admin
route is going to go into Studio
so Studio doesn't do anything for
routing admin is where the first routing
starts
so it's still at slash admin our studio
is still at slash admin
API routes can stay there can stay right
there two projects will go onto the site
if I have a con can say right there
globals will stay right there
page it goes under site so that's our
home page right there so even if it's
under slash site slash pages.tsx it's
still just a home page
all right let's close all of our editors
there's some stuff going around let's go
and close all those and here let's see
and make sure everything's still there
projects project page.tsx layout dot TSX
page.tsx for the home page Studio admin
index page
cool
so admin has its own layout as well and
Studio has its own layout
so let's actually delete this admin
layout we don't need that one and there
we go so we have Studio layout
let's make sure our app still functions
as we remember it we moved around a lot
so we'll go back can't resolve
globals.css that's because we have to
update our import so we're going to site
layout
all the way at the top here we're going
to do a
dot dot since we're going up one folder
let's go back over
and
all right the studio still works very
nice and let's go make sure our home
page works
and our site works just like it did
before
and I can click into that and that works
and I have my layout applying to the
site only
and not the studio side of things
in the studio is untouched we can still
use it as we did before
I am seeing a quick problem here though
there's like this border on here I think
we actually do need the global CSS
because it is a Tailwind reset a CSS
reset so let's go back over under Studio
layout and we are going to also import
globals.css
there
all right so my mistake we do need
globals.css in this file and in our
other site layout so let's go over here
there we go no weird padding around the
edges and our home page looks good as
well and that's how we are going to use
organizational folders inside of next.js
so that we can create multiple layouts
for different routes and the child
routes underneath each of those routes
is pretty powerful stuff
all right we have a fully functioning
site so at this point we could just end
here and say we're good to go we have a
great website we have projects for
individual Pages which are coming from
our sanity studio and that is coming
from a project schema type
we have learned all about next 13 and
how it's server side rendered how we can
use our folders as our routing and how
we can even use our folders as
organization
and we have a pretty good folder
structure here
we've dropped in the sanity Studio but I
think we can take a take this a little
bit further I want to do one more thing
and let's go ahead and talk about it
so we are going to add a Pages schema
type
So currently we have projects we're
going to add pages and this is going to
be so we can add pages like an about
page or a contact page
so I'm going to close everything
let's close this let's close this and
let's go into sanity schemas and we're
going to create a new page Dash schema
and this is cool because now we have all
of our schemas in one folder we have our
Barrel file here
so let's go ahead and create page Dash
schema dot TS
I'm going to say cons pages is equal to
and very similar to how we did the
project schema
we could go and copy and change some
things but repetition makes for great
learning so we're going to keep going
here so name is Page title is going to
be plural for pages and capitalize and
type is going to be document remember
name title type
and now we get to our type
Fields so our Fields arrays we're going
to have
a bunch of objects so name title type
again name is title title is going to be
title lots of titles
um type is going to be string
all right let's keep going here the next
one is going to be name is Slug
title is Slug
and like we did for the project schema
we're going to we're going to say type
is Slug
and like the project schema we're going
to add some options here we're going to
say options is an object
source is going to be from the title but
unlike the project one where we did
Source over there we're going to also
add max length is 96. so you can Define
validation there
and then the last field we're going to
add is content
perfect and so just like the project
schema this one is going to be a type
array and it's going to be of
type
is block and this is going to be our
block content now that's all it takes to
Define this object which is our page
schema and let's just export it out of
this file export default page
now we have to make sure that sanity
knows about this so we're going to go
into index.ts inside of our schemas
folder and add it right in here we have
project we have page now and we'll do
the same thing here we're going to bring
that in from page
just like that
all right so we can make sure that this
is coming in from our sanity studio now
because it's in the sand in the schemas
array so we'll go over to our studio
refresh that
and now we have Pages fantastic
so let's create a couple
let's say an about page will generate a
slug and I'll just say I am the about
page
look at all the cool stuff here and I'll
put a bold on that
we can even put an underline somewhere
in there we can just show the formatting
on the front page
and then we'll do first second third
bullet points
just to have that
okay so publish that and let's go ahead
and create another one we'll do contact
and the slug will just generate
you can find me on Twitter at at kapehe
underscore okay and we can even take
this right here and click on this link
and I'll type it in right here and you
can actually find me on Twitter at
kapehe underscore okay
all right so
that URL is on there
it is linked perfect so now we have our
link we can click publish
document was published and now we have
two pages that we can work with so let's
go back over to our code
and we are going to get our sanity utils
open and what we're going to do is we're
going to create two functions to get all
pages
and a function to get a single page so
just like we did for projects here we
have get projects get project I'll do
the same thing here export
async function get Pages plural
export async function get page singular
and we're going to pass in the slug
and now just like the projects and
project we're going to do create a type
we're going to create a type so let's go
over here to our types folder
I'll create a page.ts and you'll notice
I'm moving a little bit faster than we
did before and that's because a lot of
this stuff is what we did in the project
schema type and bringing all that data
in
so we're going to move a little bit
faster
export type
page is equal to this object right here
we're going to have ID
which comes from sanity created at which
comes from sanity as well and that's a
date and then we have the fields that we
created so title which is a string slug
string content which is going to be
portable text block
and it's going to be an array
and we're going to import that
portable text block from sanity
all right so now we've defined our page
type and now we can use it insanity
utils and that's the only place we're
really going to use it since sanity
utils
uh we'll pass along to every other page
that will use it
so we're going to say this returns a
promise of pages an array of those
and let's make sure we do our import
right there and this will return a
promise
or a single page perfect
all right let's type in both of these
I'm going to click here and ALT click
here we'll press enter and then these
are going to start the same way return
create client
client config.fetch
and then we're going to pass in a grot
query here
just like this with the back ticks
and now let's create these separately so
this one
we are going to say asterisk to grab all
the data and we're going to open up our
brackets to get
type is equal to page so get all the
pages now we're going to filter down to
what exactly we want
so we're going to grab the ID
created a title
slug remember we're going to create that
Alias so slug
is now slug.current we should also bring
in content here
but we're getting a list of our pages
and I'm thinking we're going to put this
in the nav bar so we aren't going to
show the content in the nav bar so I'm
going to remove that actually
and this is only the stuff that we're
going to use so we can create a list of
links to each page
all right let's do the same thing
for down here
let's go for asterisks to grab
everything
underscore type is equal to
page and slug dot current
is equal to Slug and remember what is
going to bring back all the pages to
match this it's going to give it as an
array but we only want the first one so
we're going to do that right there and
then we're going to pretty much copy
everything that's up here
like that
we're going to bring it down grab all
the same stuff but here
this is for an individual page so we are
going to go ahead and grab the content
this time
and let's pass in the slug so that it
knows to use the slug and let's also
give the slug a type of string
just like that
okay
now we have created both of our
functions for get pages and get page and
that's kind of how I like to do our
setup we will create the schema we'll
create some content we'll create our
utility functions to go get that content
and then we'll create our types to make
sure it's all typesafe
so looking good first up let's close all
these editors and start from a good
place
we're going to go into the app folder
site layout and I'm going to go grab all
of our pages
right here
get all of our pages
and I'm going to say const pages
is equal to a weight get pages
just like that and since we have an
await we have to async this right here
and get Pages needs to be imported I'll
click This little light and Sanity utils
so if I scroll up there you can see it's
imported from at sanity slash
sanity Dash utils now the next thing we
need to do is show all of these Pages as
links so here in the header right next
to the logo I will say div
div
and then right here let's map over all
these pages so we'll say pages.map
page
and we're going to create a link
and make sure we put a key in there
because react wants that key
so page dot ID is going to be our key
we'll close that link
cool and then page dot title
and we're going to add the href here for
Slash
slug
and that'll be page dot Slug and I'm
going to do that right inside of forward
slash so that's not going to be slash
projects or slash anything else it's
going to be right in the home page slash
the slug and that's because these are
pages so we don't want it to be slash
about or we do want it to be slash about
or slash contact content contact
so let's take a look at where this looks
on our site
it looks good we have contact and about
and each of these links and you see at
the bottom left slash about and slash
contact
so let's style them out a bit so they
sit next to our logo instead of
underneath so go to the header and
you're going to say class name is going
to be Flex
items Center
and we're going to go for justify
between so that we can push the contents
of this header to the left and to the
right
and then over here we need to have these
sit next to each other
so let's say class name
is equal to flex item Center and let's
give it a gap of maybe three so there's
some spacing between those
all right
that looks good
these are a little bit too dark let's go
ahead and shrink these down too so Tech
small and text Gray Maybe 600.
and let's bring up the Gap to about five
cool so let's go take a look
all right that looks a lot better our
logos over there our two links are over
there let's make sure we have an
indicator that they're hoverable
so we're going to say class name
this is hover underline
let's take a look
there we go now it's not the prettiest
hover action but it does indicate that
those are links
just like we did for the projects we
want to link over each individual one so
let's click on an individual and this
will 404 because we haven't created this
page just yet
so to do that
we are going to go back over to our
folder structure inside of site
we are going to have a new file we're
going to say slug is the dynamic route
and in next 13 we have a page.tsx
underneath it to make it a real route
all right so let's export default async
function page and that's going to get
params from next
cool and then we are going to take
prams.slug
and we are going to get a single project
so we're going to say cons project is
equal to a weight get project
prams.slug we have to fix a couple
things here let's fix this params error
right here it probably wants to type so
we'll say type props is equal to params
which is an object that has slug which
is a string let's give that to this
function right here
that one's good next up we need to
import get project we'll click on the
light bulb and click that to import from
sanity utils
and next up we have to return
oh
actually I'm seeing we're getting a
project and we need to get a page so I'm
actually going to select both of these
and type in get page
that was a good catch so let's return
now a div
let's say page dot title and I see I did
it again
this also needs to be paid right here so
sorry about that
all right looks good let's just go ahead
get all of our styling in right here
let's go in there let's give
an H1 wrap around this
um then we'll do class name and we're
pretty much going to copy everything
from the project
so let's go ahead and go back to
projects page.tsx we're going to copy
everything in this H1 right here
so
get that copy that we'll take that go
back over to the slug page.tsx
and just paste that right in there
after our H1 we're going to show the
content of this page and we're going to
just drop that in using the portable
text component so portable
text
value is equal to page dot content just
like we did for project and let's wrap
this in a div and give it some styles
so we'll do class name
we'll do text large text Gray
at 700 and margin top 10.
and we need to import portable text we
need we'll click on the little light
bulb and import from portable text react
and that should be good enough to show
our page content so let's see let's go
back we'll refresh
and there we go check that out and it
even gives the list items but Tailwind
by default removes the bullet point
things so we would have to bring in
something like Tailwind Pros classes to
get this to look good but we do have our
underline let's click on contact
and you see this is a link that still
needs styling you could definitely bring
in Tailwinds topography plug-in to get
some Styles in but overall we have a
great site we have our logo that goes
back to the home page we have our
projects we have our nav
that links to Dynamic pages and I'll
click about here
and it has Dynamic content and if I went
back to my studio and added a new page
it would also show up right here and the
content would be updated as well so
really cool stuff and now that we've
shown a list of them in addition to a
single one of these schema schema types
I think it's some good practice for how
you can work with sanity studio and
next.js applications
so we have our application on localhost
3000 running nicely and all of our
sanity content is coming from sanity's
content link
The Next Step here is to get this thing
deployed and have a live website so I'm
going to go to my GitHub I already made
a GitHub repo for this so you're going
to need to make a GitHub repo from the
code that you have locally
if you go into vs code and you go into
your git panel
over on the left here you should see the
little git GitHub icon you can commit
everything and you should be able to see
a published repository button
and that way you can click that and you
can create a brand new repo in GitHub
all from inside of vs code it's pretty
slick
so that's what I did and over here is my
GitHub repo
now we are going to take this repo and
let's deploy it to Purcell it just makes
sense to deploy next.js to herself so
let's
go to the dashboard for myversell and
I'll click add new
and we'll get a new project
and we have our repos right here it
already shows the one that I just
created four minutes ago I'm going to go
ahead and click import
project name is nexanity framework
preset next JS and these defaults are
pretty good we don't have to change out
environment variables because all of our
authorization happens on the sanity side
of things so nothing needs to happen
inside of this repo
we'll click deploy and how easy was that
I jumped past the deploy loading screen
if you noticed all right so we have our
site deployed to this nice little
preview and it pulled in the content in
the preview
let's go ahead go back to our dashboard
we'll click on this new project that we
just created and
we can click visit right here to see
this live in a website
so there we go
just like it looked on local really nice
live and accessible to anyone that we
send the link to
so the next step is let's see what the
admin dashboard looks like so I want to
show you something really cool let's say
that the studio is right here at slash
admin
and
to access our content remember earlier
we need to add the following URL as a
course origin to our sanity project and
that makes sense because sanity security
says that you have to Define what
domains are going to be able to access
your content so I'll get this and we'll
click continue
and right away it opens up my sanity
dashboard I have to sign in I'm going to
sign in with Google
and
and just like that it's already Auto
filled so with the course origin and I
click add core's origin and it kicks me
right back to the studio and I can log
in with Google Now
and I have access to my live studio from
the URL that versell gave me at slash
admin
so I want to show you something super
cool uh here I have the studio up on
this tab let's bring the live studio
over to the right and I'm using split
view right here so the left is the local
Studio
and you can see localhost 3000 the right
is the deployed version and what's cool
is if I click into Pages it looks like I
am in contact over here
you can see that I'm editing this
document over on my local Studio
and I can click here and now
the local Studio can see that I'm
editing on the production side on the
deployed side and this is API presence
API at work so I'm going to go ahead and
edit this on the live site and we'll say
can't wait to chat
and immediately you saw it happen on the
left side and look how powerful that is
even if you're working in local versus
the deployed site you still get that
real-time update because all this is
backed up by sanity's content like
so
you can go ahead and click publish here
let's go back and view the site
so this is going to be this site
localhost let's go to the contact page
can't wait to chat shows up here and
I'll go back to my versel dashboard
click visit right here
go to contact and on the deployed side
there it is can't wait to chat also
updated so really great way to see the
flow of content from our studio even if
you're working locally or on the
deployed side it shows up directly on
the website and remember next.js uses
react server components and takes care
of pre-rendering and caching for you so
that it's fast
all right that's a great look at
everything we could build today and we
went from having no nexjs website to
creating our own next site adding in the
sanity Studio
so we have a slash admin route to work
in and we have our content that we can
update that updates on our website as we
create it
I'll be sure to live leave the GitHub
repo in the description below
but if you want to learn more about
sanity
definitely check out the sanity.io crash
course
uh
you can find it on the sanity.io YouTube
channel
and that's a great way to learn more
about sanity and get a full crash course
into it you can find me at kapehe
underscore okay over on Twitter
I always love to see what you're
building please let me know if you found
this tutorial helpful I love hearing
from all of you I had a lot of fun
building this and I hope you did too
thank you to free code camp for letting
me be on this channel and make sure to
smash that like button so we'll see in
the next one thanks everyone and aloha
again thank you so much for hanging out
I'm excited to see all of your projects
up and running with nextjs and sanity.io
if you want to take it one step further
you can join the next JS Discord
Community you can find more information
there and the link to join at nextjs.org
blog slash Discord so definitely check
that out also the next JS docs are
awesome so head on over to nextjs.org
docs to learn more about next
the sanity crash course that I was
talking about as one of my projects can
be sound found at sanity's YouTube
channel
sanity.io
sanity.io crash course and then the
sanity Community has awesome people that
can be found at slack.sanity.io and the
handy dandy sanity.io docs can be found
at sanity.io docs if you want to learn
more about sanity but definitely check
out all those links
and you can find me on Twitter at kapehe
underscore okay if you want to tag me in
any of your finished projects I'd love
to check them out Mahalo everyone for
joining and I will see you around